So the first main topic we'll introduce is symmetric cryptosystems.
Symmetric means both encryption and decryption are done with the same key.
I want to introduce some terminology that we'll use throughout the course.
So we can think of encryption as a function,
and it takes as input a plain text--this is the unencrypted message--
it outputs a ciphertext, and then our goal is to be able
to send that ciphertext over an insecure channel.
This could be a wireless network, this could be the internet,
this could be a courier carrying your message,
any channel where we can't trust the channel to be secure.
We hope what comes out of the channel is the same ciphertext we put into it.
Then that goes into a decryption function, and what comes out
is the message that we sent it.
Our cast of characters--we often talk about Alice sending the message,
Bob receiving it.
We also have malicious characters who might be listening in on this channel.
One of those is called Eve--for eavesdropper--and she has really big ears
and can hear the messages sent between Alice and Bob,
but she only hears what's sent over the insecure channel,
she doesn't have access to the plain text--that's the input to the encryption function--
or the plain text that comes out of the decryption function at the other end.
But she can hear the ciphertext that's sent over the insecure channel.
To think about this a little more precisely,
the plain text is some message, and it's selected from a set of messages.
So, M is the set of all possible messages,
and M could be finite--for a given length, M is finite--
and we'll often be thinking about fixed-length messages,
so there's a finite set of them, and M is some message selected from that set.
The ciphertext is C--selected from the set of all possible ciphertexts,
and the encryption and decryption functions are functions.
The encryption function--as shown here--
is a function that goes from an element of M to an element of C.
The decryption function goes from an element of C--a ciphertext--to an element of M.
In order for Bob to receive the same message as the one Alice encrypted,
we need this property--that the D function is an inverse of the M function.
So we need it to be the case for all messages.
The result of decryption the encryption of that message is the same as the message we started with.